In tough economic times,...
...even a trip to the grocery store means balancing healthy family meals with the need to keep expenses down.
For a healthy balanced diet, you need a good mixture of protein, carbohydrates, veggies and whole grains.
Keeping your cost low means cutting back on restaurant food...
...and most prepared food in grocery stores.
A whole chicken costs for only about two bucks a pound.
A pound of beans will set you back a whole buck fifty.
Potatoes, look at these complex carbs, at 89 cents a pound.
What this means is cooking.
Bust out those cookbooks.
And remember, the best part of home cooking is the leftovers.
Don't ignore packaged foods entirely.
You can find great deals on items like albacore tuna and brisling sardines...
...which are not only cheap, but a great source of protein and essential fatty acids.
Visit cheapcooking.com or sardinediet.com.